the White House going the extra mile to
protect the oldest president in history
while the Democrats unleash on his
biggest rival Politico reporting Biden
downplays age talk but subtle
accommodations are being made team Biden
is secretly helping Joe avoid countless
embarrassing moments like when he
stumbles up the stairs so what's their
solution
give him shorter stairs to get on and
off Air Force One I wish I was kidding
Biden uses small steps to board every
flight on his recent NATO trip they're
also making Biden changes Footwear Joe
is rocking casual sneakers instead of
dress shoes which can be more prone to
slipping there is however one top Biden
Challenger who doesn't need
accommodations to run for the presidency
Democrats berated and censored RFK Jr
during yesterday's government censorship
hearing and now they're defending their
behavior
what is the fear of having RFK Jr come
to the hill to testify what are you
afraid that he would say I'm not afraid
of anything he would say I just don't
want to hear him rfkate Junior's point
that he is being censored by democrats
I don't think you want to bring bigots
before the Congress I'm trying to censor
him today proved his point that he is
being the censor him we were trying to
make sure that he didn't cause more harm
with his outrageous testimony oh that's
not censorship censorship with not being
allowing someone to speak he can speak
and here's how you know that that RFK is
getting under their skin the media is
now comparing him to to him
parallels between Trump and Bobby
Kennedy Jr are kind of stunning they'll
throw these grenades out and let them
explode and then walk away and go look I
didn't do anything we have now opened
this uh can of worms where kind of
contrarian eccentric candidates are
running and it was Donald Trump first in
the Republican party and now we're
seeing it in the Democratic party I have
not wanted to enable
his access
to the drug addiction
that he has never conquered
the drug addiction
that has been with him for all of his
adult life
the addiction
to attention
thank you
I don't even know what to ask after
hearing that but Jesse I'll start with
you
um let's start with the what's going on
on Air Force One the Democrats have no
choice to protect Biden because they
know that we're not in the mood for
Kamala to be the president and uh so are
you surprised that they stick to
supporting by uh Biden through his age
concerns and trashing someone younger
like RFK no they hate RFK
and Biden hates RFK Biden's always
wanted to be a Kennedy except you didn't
have the money and so he tried to get
the money under the table but remember
when he was young and was in the late
70s early 80s he had some hair and he
was thin and athletic and he was the new
guy and he kind of aspired to be Camelot
from Delaware but he was broke and so we
had this new guy coming up who's
embarrassing Joe Biden he's getting a
lot more attention he's obviously more
physically fit and so he used his
lackeys on that hearing to destroy this
man with innuendo and and smears Debbie
Wasserman Schultz to say that he has
caused harm she accused him he said this
thing over the weekend about the bio
weapons and she said he had caused a
rise in anti-semitic hate crimes
that was Thursday she she's saying in
four days rfk's comments that maybe we
played here on Fox and was online caused
people to attack Jewish people
physically she can't point to one
example of that in terms of the sneakers
the sneakers Joe's wearing are
comfortable
the American people don't care what
sneakers he wears the American people
don't care what flight of stairs he goes
up in Air Force One the American people
care about the crime the border the high
prices and the fact that this guy's
taking bribes and the entire Federal
bureaucracy is covering it up that's
what people care about you know Katie
these Democrats are so threatened by
free speech that they don't even want to
give RFK an opportunity to come out and
speak at a censorship hearing and it
shows how afraid they are of someone who
goes against their their ideology well
it also is just an indictment of their
broader thoughts on free speech and just
giving someone the ability to say what
they want to and then making a better
argument about why it's wrong I mean if
they've gone from Liberal philosophy to
leftist philosophy which includes
censorship and it's not just with RFK
it's with anybody who disagrees with
them we saw this throughout covid with
big Tech you know if you talked about
Afghanistan in the wrong way the
administration would go to big Tech can
try to get some of that stuff censored
and taken down so that's just how they
operate they want censorship instead of
a free expression of ideas and debate to
win an argument but it was really
interesting yesterday during the hearing
when Democratic Congressman Jerry
Connolly said that RFK brings shame onto
the Kennedy name it's like I think
there's a few Kennedys uh in the family
who probably brought some more shame on
the family Ted Kennedy comes comes to
mind but you're right I mean they're
terrified of him because he's pulling at
17 percent but he's not a conservative
like he was on air yesterday with Martha
saying that he agreed with the
administration's bailout of student
loans I mean he's not a conservative and
yet the media is attacking him like he
is what's interesting Greg is the fact
that rfk's numbers have gone down he
started at 20 that he was I think 19 and
now he's 17. I mean is the is the
Democrat machine so strong that they're
telling Democrats initially inclined to
favor him to you know get rid of him
it's hard to say because right now I can
measure anything because everybody's
outside
but you know what bothers me it doesn't
really bother me the accusations of an
addiction to attention
coming from a TV host yeah an occupation
that is driven by the need for attention
do you have a passion for patriotism in
the country and and family and that's
the only reason why you're doing that
Lord O'Donnell though never says no to a
camera I mean he's been in movies TV
shows he's got his own show so even the
way he was delivering that was like I am
playing a TV host and this is incredible
but what they're doing with Joe and the
stairs is uh reminds me what you do to
an aging parents home you know you
install handrails get rid of the
slippery surfaces he's one step away
from Assisted Living I think a great
sitcom would be an assisted living a
reality show with uh people like Biden
Nadler Pelosi Feinstein just get them
all in one room it'd be it would be
smelly but it would be funny I think the
Democrats responding to RFK is the same
reason why Jessica responds the same way
they see Republicans using him as a
battering ram against against Biden and
I think it's a you have to admit it's a
fair suspicion because we would feel the
same way if the Democrats Embrace let's
say an Insurgent Republican like say
Trump uh and and I do think however that
RFK has some exceptions and he is a
liberal but there's an overlap on speech
and on vaccines in both cases there's a
Descent of fascism on the left when
they're going after speech and they're
demanding that you get the shots or else
and they had their way people lost their
jobs people were trapped at home
destroyed this country for two years and
that was it was a fascist activity so
there are similarities and it's true he
is like Trump
um and you can see it from the critics
perspective they take his words and they
interpret them in the very worst way you
possibly can never mind his deeds we
know that RFK Jr Left Right Center
whatever has done a lot of great things
he believes in it he reads he's a good
person right uh but the longer he lasts
the deeper this animosity towards him
will be and they will continue to look
at his words the way they did to Trump
and now you know this is true because
they called him a bigot and this is
exactly what happened to Trump it's like
the when the b word or the r word comes
out then you know you know
they're scared of him because that's
what they did to Trump but you know they
got to take RFK seriously because who
else he got you got a babbling goofball
as a VP
um RFK says provocative stuff but this
is America free speech that's all he's
got to say you you disagree with him you
go like freedom of speech look at my
deeds and that's exactly what why uh why
Trump was a good president and white
people like Trump has took away the
obnoxiousness of some of the things he
said the Deeds were right there and he
did he did a good job
Jessica why is it that the Democrats all
of a sudden have this totalitarian
instinct to shut people down to claim
that what they're saying is
disinformation misinformation or mal
information where they admit that what
Kennedy's saying is true but it doesn't
jive with their ideology I mean where
did that come from all of a sudden
people aren't capable of deciding issues
no I I think so first of all when we're
talking about the censorship and I
mentioned this yesterday but it's
important to reiterate RFK Jr began his
statement by saying I was censored by
the Trump Administration and I was
censored by the Biden Administration the
hunter Biden laptop story happened in
October of 2020 When Donald Trump was
the president his administration made
the same kinds of requests of big Tech
to take things down
the FBI is out of control yeah it wasn't
Trump yeah the Trump appointed the FBI
has been against Trump and four Biden
for six years
we know what it was like when Trump was
President he didn't have a friend among
Republicans especially the state
department especially the FBI Donald
Trump my heart breaks for you okay
let's talk about
your guys's boyfriend RFK Jr so first of
all he's pulling at 14 not 17 the reason
it's going down is people are hearing
him and they don't like what he has to
say because he has no agenda that speaks
to the Democratic party and our values
he wants to talk about being anti-vaxx
which is not what we think he wants to
do videos at the border and I think the
border is an important issue but you
know what I want to hear him talk about
talk about your work as an environmental
lawyer talk about what's going on with
climate change I want to talk I did no
lead with it have an a set of Economic
Policy it's also also and I get it maybe
it was 14. yesterday he's polling the
graphic box today said 17. okay well I
certainly believe in the veracity
anyway he's pulling it like point four
percent in New York obviously the guy's
going nowhere but but then why are you
so scared I'm not scared I'm honestly
not scared I and I wouldn't call him a
bigot either true but
pushing him when you have the
opportunity to get at someone to talk
about their anti-vax opinions the fact
that they have been inconsistent on this
quote censorship issue because he
doesn't go into media and I get it you
can't go to 10 o'clock on MSNBC but I'm
pretty sure that Stephanie rule would
interview at 11 o'clock and that he
could go talk to a lot of journalists
that actually speak to a heavily
Democratic audience and the thing is
when you testify you are a republican
witness and then you go and I think
Martha did a great job but you go and
you are with Martha McCallum and then on
Tuesday night he'll be in a town hall
with Sean Hannity and I think Sean does
a great job and Gavin Newsom was very
smart to go on with him but if you are
talking to the Democratic base that's
not who's watching Hannity and we can
all admit I would hope CNN invited him
to do it now
there's a contradiction here when he's
not on he says why doesn't he do it and
then when he's on how dare you platform
man
you can't platform him that's why he's
on Fox no that's we will platform anyone
I'm the evidence of that 100 yes to that
we finally agree on something but I
would find it really hard to believe
that there wasn't one journalist on
another Network that wouldn't take him
and he did do a news Nation Town Hall
but you know what none of us know what
we're talking about as to whether one
person invited him or one person didn't
here's the bottom line
the Democrats want to shut them down and
they don't want him to speak they want a
deep platform and they want to censor
him and that's what they want to do with
Robert Kennedy I don't understand why
they're so uh offended by this guy
they're offended by him the same reason
he said he's vaccines
and he has been he's not always happy I
had Democrats with a ridiculous new
claim the bad investigating the bidens
here's another one is dangerous hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now